leute was geht ab schönen guten morgen
es ist gerade elf oder so ich weiß nach
köln
wir drehen das 300.000 abos restlichen
einfach mal ein bisschen mit wird den
cooler tag wie gehts halt gesundheitlich
nicht so gut wir fangen direkt an ich
muss los und viel spaß mit dem video
ganz gut gefällt und die öfter mal so
was sehen wollten
ein
brigitte buhse hätten am dienstag in
köln
wir sind jetzt hier im studio dass der
joscha kindern spaß
wir fangen jetzt gleich mit dem ganzen
an ich halte euch bisschen auf dem
laufenden gleich gehen wir noch was
essen
aber wir wollen ja feststellen heute
deswegen halten wir uns richtig ran oder
was geht wir sind jetzt fertig wird
drehen wir jetzt ein bisschen rausfahren
und ihr euch natürlich auch mit nein
nur verschieben
juni
bist du sie
von bis
naja
jojo es ist jetzt halb neun ich muss
jetzt wieder nach hause
am wunderschönen deutzer bahnhof und
dank jascha das du hat kameramann macht
bzw die geilen aufnahmen gemacht hast
wir sehen uns morgen wieder kommt ein
neues geiles video ich hoffe dieses
wieder wegfallen wenn ihr bock habt auf
das 300.000 special lassen doch nach
oben da würd sagen wir sehen uns diese
zwei stunden zugfahrt peace